[Music]
Um, hey everyone. Glad you're all here.
This is the reasoning and reinforcement
learning track uh on the afternoon of
the last day of the AI engineer world's
fair. Glad you're all here. Glad you're
sharing it with us. Today, what I'm
going to talk about is uh a very
specific case study um that we did. Uh
this case study, I'm going to talk about
lessons learned very concretely. Um what
did and didn't work, how we able to
build an agent that worked well with
reinforcement learning. Uh all of this
uh everything that I'm talking about in
this presentation, this is an open-
source codebase that we built. Um we
wanted to share these learnings and I'll
I'll I'll share that link with you at
the end as well. Um for those of you who
want to replicate what we did um so what
is the project we're going to be talking
about? It's a project called ART E. It
is a natural language uh assistant that
helps you answer questions from your
email inbox. So I'll give you an example
of what we're talking about here. Um
let's say you want to ask, you know, in
this case our example question is when
is Sherry's move to Portland targeted
for? So you would ask this question to
the assistant. It then goes and it
searches your inbox. It's got several
tools. So it has like a search tool, it
has a read email tool, and then it can
actually answer the final question. You
can kind of see if you if you look here
what's going on behind the scenes. This
is important so you get a sense of kind
of how this agent works and as we're
talking through how we built it, how we
made it work. Um hopefully that that
helps uh make the conversation very
grounded in a specific task. So anyway,
you see the agent, it's it's you know
searching for certain keywords. It get
those messages back. It's in reading one
of them and and answering the question.
That's that's what it does. Okay. So um
question, you know, once once we've
decided this is kind of the the task
we're trying to solve, why would you re
use reinforcement learning for this
specifically? Um and uh and the answer
is like to start with you shouldn't. In
fact to start off with we did not. Um so
the first version of this agent once we
decided we wanted to build this we did
we didn't use any reinforcement learning
at all. We purely built this on prompted
models and this is the first lesson from
this talk uh that I want to share is I
would generally always recommend
starting with getting the best
performance you can with a prompted
model before going to any training
including reinforcement learning.
There's a few different reasons to do
that uh 3 in specifically. Um the first
one is just like working out the bugs in
your environment, right? Um you know,
maybe your tools aren't implemented
properly, maybe they don't have access
to the data you think they do. Um we
find this happens a lot and it's a lot
less frustrating to debug that uh you
know, separately from debugging your
your training loop. So you want to make
sure that like you can get at least some
kind of performance um before you start
training. Um and then second of all, you
may find as you're trying to improve the
performance on uh on using these
prompted models that uh you can get it
working really well and that's great. So
that means you don't need to train
anything. Um and that saves you a lot of
time. Um there's a third reason as well
uh that I'll share which is uh basically
once you've gone to that effort, you've
done your best to get the best quality
prompted baselines you possibly can. Um
then uh if you find that those baselines
are not able to get you where you need
to go and you're able to surpass them
with re reinforcement learning, it feels
great. You get to glow and be like,
"Yes, I was able to beat the the
frontier models on my task." Um this
this I I highly recommend it. Feels
good. You can you can like post on X
about it. there's there's nice, you
know, graphs and stuff. So, this is this
is what it looks like when everything
goes right. Um, so this is an example of
a training run for this art e model that
I'm going to be talking about. Uh, you
can see that there's these these lines
for each of the prompted model baselines
that we've got. Um, so we've got 03, 04
mini, and then Gemini and and 4.1. And
you can see uh those ones, you know,
they have certain level performance. And
then you can see this this uh sort of
moving line um that's going on. This is
the model that we trained. And you can
see it actually starts out significantly
worse than these other models uh from
from the start. That's because we
started from a Quen 2.5 the 14 billion
parameter one. It's a relatively small
model, relatively weak model. Um and so
it was doing much worse than these
initially, but you can see as training
progresses um you know initially at the
beginning it it's sort of maybe maybe
there's it's learning the right way to
do tool calls. There's a very sharp bump
as it figures out the basic stuff and
then a more gradual climb until
eventually it's able to significantly
outperform uh any of the prompted models
on this task. And this is sort of what
you're you know in the ideal case when
everything works this this is what
you're looking for. This is what what
you're hoping to achieve. Um this is
another view actually of that same data
we were just looking at. Um I I like I
wanted to highlight it in this way
because it's important to realize. So on
the last graph it looked like the the
lines sort of asmtote out pretty close
together. That's because they're getting
near 100%. But the last um you can see
for example with our best prompted model
here 03 uh it's 90% accuracy and with
our RL model we're able to get up to
96%. And so one way to think about that
is like 60% of the errors that 03 was
making um are are actually solved with
our model. Um which is which is quite a
large uh you know we find that that's
actually can be very very important for
the user experience of someone using one
of these um if you're getting you know
just half as many errors uh that that
can make the product much stronger. Um
so this is this is where we got to on
accuracy. There's a couple other metrics
that we find are often very very
important. Um and you know the trade-off
between these does does is very task
dependent but but they matter in many
cases. Um cost obviously is a big one.
So for for this email agentic harness
that we had we benchmarked the cost on
034 mini and our model. So if you wanted
to do like a thousand searches using 03
that's going to cost $55. Um which is a
lot. I think for most use cases that
probably would be cost prohibitive just
from a unit economics point of view. Um
on 04 mini we're down to $8 but that's
still quite expensive. And then we drop
another order of magnitude by moving to
this smaller Quen 2.514B. Again, this is
just driven it by being it being a much
smaller model. So it's it's much cheaper
to run. Um but we're still able to get
very good performance because we've
specialized it on our task. Um beyond
cost and the accuracy, um the third
metric that often comes up is latency.
Uh particularly if you're doing I mean
certainly anything with voice, but if
there's any real-time human interaction
with the task, latency is going to
matter a lot. Um, and we were able to
find on on this task we were able to get
significantly better latency. There's a
number of different ways which I'll go
into in more detail later that we were
able to achieve this. Um, you know, one
was just again moving to a smaller model
helps. There's just less less loading
from memory, less matrix multiplies.
It's just you're able to get tokens out
faster. Um, we were also able to train
this model to have fewer turns going
back and forth with the database with
the actual email um the list of emails.
Uh, we we were able to train it to be
more efficient with its queries. Um, and
I'll go to that in a moment. And so that
that leads to lower latency. Um there's
actually a third thing which we didn't
apply here but can help a lot with these
smaller things which is called
speculative decoding. That's something
you can do on large or small models. It
generally works better on smaller task
specific models because you get higher
um acceptance rates on on your
speculator. But basically um there's
there's lots of reasons why smaller
models work better. Um okay. So then the
next question uh for those of you who
haven't done this yet is like okay what
is the effort required to do this to
actually achieve these results? Um, if
you'd asked me this question a year ago,
I would say, "Hey, you should really
only be doing this if you know you're
this big company and willing to put, you
know, months of of work into a project."
I think that's changing. I honestly do.
Um, in this case, uh, so this this
training run, it cost us about $80 in
GPU time. It did take about a week of
engineering time to build this. And and
caveat that was with an engineer who is
familiar with this domain and and had
quite a lot of experience uh, you know,
with machine learning and RL. Um but I
actually expect as as we figure out the
right patterns here collectively as an
industry this will keep dropping. Um and
I expect that uh you know the sort of
payback period to get a return on
investment from these specialized models
is actually going to continue falling as
well. Um and uh you know part of part of
the reason I wanted to give this talk is
to sort of distribute that know the
knowledge we learned and hopefully move
faster towards that that world where
this is just sort of like a thing
everyone knows how to do and it's very
easy and very fast. Um, so that's that's
what we'll be talking about for the rest
of time is is some more of the lessons
we learned. Um, okay. So, uh, when you
are using RL to train an agent or really
using RL for anything else, um, I find
that consistently with different
problems we look at, there are there are
sort of two hard problems that come up
every single time. All right? Um, and
the two hard problems are first of all
figuring out a realistic environment,
right? So if you're training an agent,
you need to be training it with
realistic data, with realistic inputs
and outputs, tools available, everything
like that to how it's going to be used
in production. Um because if you don't,
then it's going to be optimizing for the
wrong thing and and you won't get the
results you want when you deploy it. And
then the second thing which sometimes is
hard um sometimes isn't this one is a
little bit test dependent is getting the
right reward function. So reward
function that just means you have to be
able to know when your agent's gone
through and say in this case give it an
answer to my email. You have to have
some way of knowing did it do a good job
or a bad job. All right, that's the
reward function. It decides it it it's
it's how you decide if it's good or it's
bad. Um some depending on the domain
sometimes that's really easy. We have I
don't know if Nathan's here, he's going
to be talking next, but um you know he
and his team put together this thing
called RLVR which in some verifiable
domains it's actually very easy to do a
reward. Often times uh not all domains
are like that. oftentimes it is kind of
hard. Um, and so it's it's somewhat task
dependent. I'm going to go through how
we solve these problems specifically
with RE. Okay, first one, realistic
environment. So for our RE task, what is
the environment we need? What is the
environment this agent's going to be
operating in? Well, it needs these tools
available. It needs to be able to go and
query an email inbox. It needs to be
able to like get emails back um and and
that look realistic. These emails, you
know, the inbox should be large because
that's what most email inboxes are like.
Um the emails in it should be diverse
and they have to look kind of like real
emails. Um so this could be kind of hard
because you can't just go ask like a
thousand people to you know give you uh
their their their personal emails to
train on. Um luckily in this case we
were able to solve this with the help of
a company that has contributed a lot um
to just the open data ecosystem uh
generally. It's it's like a quite an
iconic company perhaps I would call it a
historic company. Um I'm of course
talking about Enron. Um
I'm hearing some laughter. So anyway,
Enron was a uh they were a financialized
energy company in the '9s and 2000s,
committed massive fraud, ended up
getting shut down by the Department of
Justice. As part of this uh um you know,
process, the the the court cases they
were going through. Um a dump of like
500,000 of their emails was released to
the public as part of the discovery
process. Um so that's that's that's
great for things like this and that's
what we used as our environment for the
email inboxes. All right. So now we've
got realistic email inboxes um with tens
of thousands of emails that are real
emails back and forth. Now we have to
design our reward function. So as our
agent is going and as our agent is um
you know we're asking it questions and
then it's giving us answers, we have to
know is the answer correct or not so we
can reward it when it gets the answer
right and it can learn to do that
better. There's different ways and this
part is very task dependent. Um the way
that we went about it in this case um
was we basically turned it into a more
of a verifiable problem. And the way we
did that was we actually took our email
inbox. We sort of inverted the problem.
We um we grabbed batches of 20 emails at
a time uh from the inbox and gave them
to Gemini 2.5 Pro and said, "Hey, given
this set of emails, give us a few
questions that a user might
realistically ask that the answers are
found in this email." Right? And so
Gemini generated the questions, it
generated the answers, and then of
course the the source emails that came
from. Um, and there were some extra
steps on top of that. A lot of the
questions it came up with looked a
little bit unrealistic. We had a
separate filtering step where we're
like, okay, let's find the subset of
these that that actually look like
questions that, you know, I would maybe
ask. And we ended up with a list of a
few thousand questions um along with
their verified answers. Um, and so at
this point, it becomes much more of a a
sort of verified thing. the the reward
function becomes much easier because we
know what the correct answer should be.
And so the way we can tell if our agent
did a good job is we give our agent the
question, we let it go and search the
email inbox and try and find the right
emails and everything. And eventually it
comes back with an answer. And then we
can just use an LLM as judge, a very
simple one, and say like, hey, you know,
here's the question. Here's the the
golden answer that that we believe is
right. Here's the answer we got from our
from our model. Is it right or not? Um
we did have to do a little bit of uh
iteration there making sure that the
judge was well calibrated on like what
you know what what counts as as correct
or not but by and large this worked
pretty well um and was able to make this
more of a verified task. Um so so that's
how that's how we solved the the reward
function problem was by having that you
know turning this into something where
we had more of a golden data set. Um,
okay. So, once you've solved that
problem, those problems, once you have
your environment, once you have um your
your reward function defined, then
basically you just kind of have to run a
loop over and over and over again where
you have your agent go through and it
tries to um solve the problem and then
you figure out if it's good or it's bad.
Um, and then you just uh you know,
reward if it's if it's good and punish
if it's bad and that's it. Um, and uh,
you do this over and over and over
again. And then hopefully if you've got
everything set up right, um, it learns
what good looks like, it learns what bad
looks like, um, and it starts doing it
right. Um, and then again, this is this
is the curve we saw earlier where where
you can see it it it starts getting
better over time. Um, okay, a few other
like interesting learnings from this
project. Um, one thing is we found that
there's actually you can throw a lot of
stuff into your reward function uh
beyond just the primary thing you're
trying to solve for. And so we actually
ended up we there were like sort of
eight different little things that we
gave extra credit for. Um, and I'm going
to share two of them here. So the first
one here is um is we were trying to have
it optimized for the number of turns,
how many times back and forth, how many
times it had to query the email inbox
before it came up with the right answer.
Right? So, because the most important
thing, of course, is is getting the
answer right, but between two answers
that both get it right, we would rather
it took fewer turns back and forth
because that's fewer tokens, that's
lower latency, lower costs. Um, it's
just like a more efficient agent. So,
um, so you can see here on this first
graph that early on, while was getting
its feet wet and figuring out what
worked, it it ended up spiking up to
over six turns on average. So, it would
go back and forth a bunch of times with
the email inbox and and try and find the
right thing. But then once it was able
to like figure out how to use the tools
efficiently, figure out like you know
the the right way to construct keywords
and find the right email, it was able to
get very efficient and actually fast uh
better than any of our prompted models
uh on this metric of um using fewer
turns. And again, this was just because
we gave it a little bit of extra. It was
it was a very small amount relative to
the reward for getting it right, but a
little bit of extra credit on on using
for fewer turns and it was able to to
use that um to to optimize against that.
Um, another extra reward function we
gave it is um to try and discourage it
from hallucinating answers. So, um,
obviously the best thing is to get the
right answer. If you can't find the
right answer, it's much better to say,
hey, I don't know, than to make up an
answer in in a situation like this. So,
we basically penalized it if um if the
reward model said, "Hey, you got the
answer wrong." And but it had tried to
get an answer give an answer, that was
like a much lower reward than if it just
said, "Hey, I don't know. I can't solve
this problem." And as you can see, that
worked quite well. Um, compared to any
of the prompted models, including 03, we
ended up with a significantly lower
hallucination rate because that was part
of our reward function. Um, again, these
are these are things that are just sort
of like extra credit, but um, we found
that like you can throw in a bunch of
these and and it can jointly optimize
all of them at the same time, which is
super powerful.
Okay, I want to talk a little bit about
reward hacking. Um, it's it's something
that comes up a lot when you're trying
to do this, and it's kind of a fun thing
to talk about. Um this is an iconic
video some of you might have seen. Uh
this was released by OpenAI almost a
decade ago at this point of um they were
they were trying to uh they had this
environment where you were trying to uh
get this boat to complete a race and
instead of learning to complete uh
complete the race it learned that oh if
I just go in this like little circle
that's not even part of the racetrack I
can like just get a bunch of points. Um
and so it just started doing that over
and over and over again instead of like
actually following. Um, this is
something that comes up a lot if you're
doing reinforcement learning. And it's
basically just the difference between
um, uh, the difference between what you
actually want the model to do and what
you can measure. Um, like what you're
actually rewarding it for. And, and if
you almost always, if you let one of
these run long enough, it will figure
out some way to exploit your measure.
Um, and it will figure out some way to
to get a really high reward um, without
actually solving the problem. And you
need to just watch for that. So, I'm
going to give a couple examples here. Um
this is a this is a graph um from
another project actually not this one.
Uh so an engineer on our team was uh was
working on this game called NYT
connections. Some of you might know you
get 16 words and you have to put them in
like four groups of four. It's quite a
challenging game especially for these
language models because it requires a
lot of world knowledge and like you know
lateral thinking. Anyway, um so so they
were trying to train this model to do it
and uh it wasn't figuring out wasn't
figuring out. what if it wasn't figured
out? And then boom, you you can see here
around step 40, it just like takes off
and it's like, okay, we figured out how
to how to solve this and and this
engineer I'm I'm going to I'm going to
call out where's where's where's An on
our team? He's here at the conference.
Yeah, he's great. You should talk to him
after. But um he was like, hey, we we we
solved it. Like we got NYT connections
and like and it's like, okay, the graph
looks good. Let's look at what it's
actually doing. What it was actually
doing is it had figured out there was a
bug in how we wrote the verification.
And if it just put every single word in
every single category, it was able to
get a perfect score. um because we
weren't verifying that they were in fact
only four words uh in each category. Um
so this is another example. This is a
fun one. So I was I was training a model
um to produce really good titles for
hacker news um titles that would get a
thing upvoted. So I had this reward
model I'd trained on like existing
hacker news um articles and how many up
votes they got. And I was I was trying
to train this model to produce new
titles and it was working really well
for a while. You can see and and sort of
subjectively as well. I I looked at a
bunch of these these titles generated
and and for these first like thousand
steps or so, it was actually learning
things that I was like, "Okay, as
someone who spends way too much time on
Hacker News, yeah, that that does look
like a good title. You're you're doing a
good job." And then you can see around
step um 1200 here, it just like jumps a
bunch, right? It's like, "Okay." Um it
clearly figured something out. I don't
know what it figured out. Um but we
should look at that. Um, and so, uh,
what it turns out what the model had
figured out was that it could just
completely ignore the content of the
post and generate the same title for
every single one of them and that would
like maximize its score. So, it
generated this title, Google lays off
80% of workforce, literally every single
article, this was this was what it
labeled it as. And was like, yes, that
is going to get up on HackerNews for
sure, which which it probably would to
be fair. Um
so so anyway the way the way we solved
this um what we found is that it's it's
really important to watch out for this
solving it typically involves modifying
in some way your reward function to
penalize things like that. So in the
second example I talked about it was
actually quite an easy fix once we
identified it um which was just add an
extra LMS judge that looked at the title
looked at the content and said hey is
there anything in the title that's not
supported by the content and we added
that on and and it it actually worked
great. Um, the important thing here is
you want to be looking at your your
rollouts, not just blindly trusting the
reward function, figuring out what's
actually happening. Um, anyway, so, uh,
that's it. Um, I'm I'm almost out of
time, so I'm going to stop. Couple of QR
codes for you. Um, everything in this
presentation, and there's a much longer
write up I have of this whole project.
It includes the code. It includes the
artifacts, data sets along the way. Um,
you can you can check that out there.
Um, one more thing is, uh, we have a
Discord that's open. We have an open
source project for training
reinforcement learning models. Um we
have a discord you can go to if you're
interested in this kind of thing. Um we
we're all in there. We answer questions.
There's lots of people from the
community trying to do these things. So
if uh if you're interested in building
things with this um feel free to join
it. And yeah, happy happy to chat there.
And um yes, thank you everyone. Uh
appreciate your time.